what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
Pearl daily where I go over this week's
treachery debauchery and craziness
before I start don't forget to subscribe
to the channel and ring that
notification Bell the way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos like
the video on your way in let's get
started so today
I am going to be covering my time on
Pierce Morgan so you know the last
couple of months
you know we had a lot of a lot of drama
at jpt we had a lot of people saying
that it was just over for me and I was
just gonna cry back to Chicago I've seen
a lot of things so I was just crying by
myself and the Pierce Morgan team said
to come back on the show so I was
excited because last time they just gave
me such an easy layup that I was like I
would love to come back bring me back
they told me I was gonna come on to talk
about equal pay in women's sports so I
couldn't wait being that I played
Semi-Pro volleyball and I was actually
before YouTube took off I was going to
go play Pro in I don't know I think it
was gonna do Portugal or something I
don't even remember but but I was gonna
go play pro YouTube took off I ended up
not doing it and you know I was just
crying about how unfair it was because
we just didn't get paid enough I did
play for 16 years so you know I just was
crying and so sad that about the pay and
I was just blaming the men so I was like
let me come on and talk about how I'm
just such a freaking victim and it's so
horrible so let's play the clip of me
going on this issue of women's rights to
be paid the same as men in sport now the
Australian women's football team have
criticized the page app in the upcoming
World Cup prize money let's take a look
at what they said as a team
736 footballers had the honor of
representing their country on the
world's biggest stage this tournament
yeah many are still denied the basic
rights to organize and collectively
bargain collective bargaining has
allowed us to ensure we now get the same
conditions as the socceroos with one
exception FIFA will still only offer
women one quarter as much prize money as
men for the same achievement
well okay this is an interesting part
because if you look at the revenue for
example in 2019 FIFA generated uh 586
million pounds in total revenue the
men's uh for the 19 2019-22 cycle 5.8
billion uh record Revenue through the
men's World Cup so the women's game has
come on in Leaps and Bounds the English
lionesses fantastic win sellout crowds
they're making a lot more money they're
definitely way way further now towards
where the men are commercially than they
were but they're still a way off and
when you saw at Wimbledon for example
the men's final was watched by three
times as many people and yet they were
both free to wear on the BBC you could
watch both if you wanted to so there was
three times as much interest in the
men's game they played two sets more per
match than the women doing it the women
get equal pay I'm not quite sure why I
don't think it's a matter of equality
it's just a matter of fairness isn't it
yeah well I I won I think all of the
women should thank the men for fun
ending our leaks because most of our
leagues would not exist without the men
number one number two when we have the
same numbers then we should get the same
pay I'm sorry I play I play volleyball
at the highest level and it's like when
we make what the men make and get the
crowds that the men draw then we should
get paid the same why why is he actually
a fight for equality Grace I mean why if
if women in a particular sport for
example turned out to generate more
Revenue right because they were more
watchable and in America the women's
football team is better than the men and
they do generate even a school level far
more interest from girls than boys for
example I don't see why equality should
be the aim why shouldn't they get paid
more than the man well look I mean there
are all sorts of problems with the way
that this market for labor is basically
a market for labor works like I
personally don't think that the top
football players in the world should be
paid as much as they do I think it's
ridiculous the amount
exactly it's Market forces
the way that we decide you know who's to
just generated
personally I'm very much in favor of the
fact that they came out there and said
collective bargaining ultimately like at
the average worker in this country
hasn't had a pay rise in over a decade
how is that going to change
when they organize with one another I'm
tired of women whining at the moment the
man literally the men fund our leagues
and we will still whine that we don't
get paid enough and honestly when
athletes do [__] like this it makes all
of us look bad because instead of being
thankful for the league that we have we
go out and whine and complain about the
pay I mean as I said I'm not whining you
sound like you're maybe doing a bit of
whining but like personally I don't
think we should be whining I think
people should be organizations
join a union get out there and fight for
it should the women footballers get the
same as the men yeah I think it probably
makes sense
sense
if you look like she's coming on the
show
and you'll see and she whines about the
topic ultimately like it's not gonna
change it's not gonna change unless they
organize that's actually true across
every sector
right join a union
they have got unions let me ask you this
it on talents alone for example as a
yardstick the U.S women's football team
were beaten by a group of under 15 boys
from Texas right who were very good
under 15 boys but they're under 15 boys
team beat them I think about eight nine
mil or something so why should women
footballers who are clearly nowhere near
as good as their male counterparts just
technically why should they get paid
anything like as much money well I mean
you know it sucks doesn't it that like
as a woman yeah okay you're you play
volleyball I'm a surfer I absolutely
love surfing it's very hard for women to
build up a body strength this is
something that I've learned that very
much the hard way and so yeah by the way
there is there is equal pay yeah there
is and actually you know it it's one of
those Sports where channel will not be
as good as a man or not well it's
different it's a different sport really
it's not you know it's the same sport
but it's very different watching women's
love than is watching amanza because you
know the average male body is different
from the average woman like uh woman's
body for all this but is there any
actual technical reason why a woman
can't do with a circle what a man can do
yeah there's I mean there's loads of
reasons like it is about the upper body
strength it's about like the way that
the body is built should women Surfers
at the elite level get the same as men
like again I think it's it just is
different like it's a different kind of
game and people watch it oh you're
shaking your head no I just think when
we start making the same amount of money
as the man then we should get paid the
same as the man I don't hear the man
whining about only fan models getting
paid more than them I don't hear the men
whining about models getting paid more
than them Kendall Jenner is the highest
paid supermodel where are the male
supermodels
dominated an industry women will just
complain I mean I don't know if that's
true about any fans because there are a
lot of men on only fans as well but I
mean look the main point is I think they
make the same I have no idea why does
she talk about things she does not know
that's the crazy thing she she literally
said she says oh well men make the same
and I ask her I'm like so you you think
they make the same well I don't know
well then why why are you why is her gut
reaction to argue with me instead of
seek what is true it's like she's so
blind in her ideology
that I would know ten times more about
playing in a professional level than she
would yet she's lecturing me
and saying that we should get the equal
prize money as the men even though she
knows nothing
nothing you know I don't know much about
the World Cup so before the show I was
like let me Google this let me see let
me see the the differences in the money
the men bring in almost 7 billion from
the World Cup
the women don't even bring 1 billion
yet we we deserve equal prize money and
we still get like a third of their prize
money and the funny thing is we're
literally stealing money from the men
because what will happen is women will
whine the small percent of men will say
all right fine let's give the women what
they want let's take a little bit of the
money from the men and give it to the
women and I guess the men are making so
much money that they're not really
paying attention but honestly if I was a
man I'd be pissed off I'd be pissed off
that women keep taking the money that
they earn to fund our leagues to fund
jobs that we don't need and in return
instead of being thankful they become
man-hating feminists who whine and
complain the other things she said she
said oh I think you're whining we just
watched a 10 minute video of women
whining about their pay if you don't
like the pay we all know this is what
irritates me we all know what we're
getting ourselves into when we go into
women's sports we all know that it is
not a high paid job every woman knows
this you know this from the time you're
like 10 years old now
is it is it fair I I think it's actually
unfair to the men because they keep
having to pay for our [__] like the WNBA
operates at a loss women's college
sports operates at a loss we don't make
money now I could actually I was
thinking about this I could see us
making money if they added in like drama
kind of like they do to the UFC where
everyone's like fighting like if they
added social media to volleyball I'm
like I could see maybe them making money
off of that like the rich you know are
they Rich soccer moms like it's totally
a thing Rich volleyball moms there's a
lot of drama in these clubs like I I
could see this happening but
my my big issue is that instead of being
thankful we whine and complain when we
could not even exist without the men
funding our leagues and feminists who
clearly like this does she know anything
about women's sports what she's a surfer
she probably like surfed twice and now
she's a a surfing expert I I don't know
I don't know who this lady is but it's
like you don't know anything and yet
you're complaining
and then
and then she has the audacity to talk
about what topic we should talk about on
Pierce Morgan's show so what does she do
she comes onto the show and whines oh
it's my show now imagine going on to
someone else's show
and not liking the topic they have for
their show
it's like what is this craziness the
point that I came on there that I wanted
to make sure was that um the like the
problem that we have in in our economy
at the moment is not that like the
average football player hasn't played
the same as the average man it is
probably an injustice and I'm glad that
they're organizing and working together
to fight for that it's probably an
injustice so through her world view
through the lens she doesn't care about
the numbers it's just probably in an
injustice like why why is she so
confidently talk about something she
does not know
she does not know Gideon just recently
released a a YouTube video of him at a
WNBA game and it was sad guys it was so
sad watching like the fans like and he
had YouTube videos at an NBA game and a
WNBA game and literally like it was so
sad to watch the level of crowds at the
highest level now look you know I I've
played in volleyball games where we had
a full stance and it was really fun but
to act like that's the norm in women's
sports it's just not it's it's just it
is what it is and we can either whine
and complain or we can try to figure out
ways to be more entertaining but women's
women women resort to whining men resort
to fixing the problem
that's the truth of the matter nobody's
getting paid enough money because
inflation's eroded people's wages even
before that no one had a pay rise in a
really long time and the lesson from
this is as I've said I'm going to say it
again because it's an important lesson
and no one knows about them anymore
because they see them as a hangout from
1970s join a union because otherwise
your boss is going to work well there
are unions for all these so they're all
it's a unions that are filing for them
exactly but okay but just as a general
point though the principle you think
that women should get paid the same even
if they're not as technically as good
and not producing as much revenue
objective judgment isn't it on whether
or not they're like technically as well
let me give you an example an example
would be the Olympics if you made it
non-gender specific how many women would
win medals well I mean no
there's no sense that the men might win
you can say like oh you know this group
is better than this group but again I
think it's different men are
women of sports yes let's not live in
this delusion and in most cases for all
people men and women want to watch men
play sports correct that's just a
demonstrable fact that may change but my
point is if it changes I don't see why
equality should be the only ambition for
the women if it turns out that in some
sport women get more viewers watching
and therefore draw more Revenue I'm more
for them getting more money than the men
can you name five WNBA players five
female soccer players I mean I can't
name any soccer players already I'm
watching the WNBA the basketball I don't
know equal pay if we would just get the
support from the family well let me tell
me let me tell you name five let me tell
you I don't even know what the WNBA is
now me I'll openly admit I cannot name
five
I don't even think I can name five
female athletes
the first one that comes to mind is
Riley Gaines the second one that comes
to mind is that Brittany Greiner chick
I got nothing like I just we don't and
I'm a female athlete I played basketball
in England I played volleyball in
England I played college volleyball
college basketball I ran track like I'm
an athlete
and I can't even name this [__] now if I
think of male basketball players to be
fair the only ones I do know are because
of like some drama they're involved in
Steph Curry well I know Michael Jordan
uh Shaq uh Tristan Thompson and
this is a little sad I don't really
watch sports like that oh oh
Derek Jeter is he a basketball player
no I thought he's something who's the
guy the guy I saw this guy playing the
Bulls a couple years ago
Jimmy Butler Jimmy Butler see five I had
it took me a second all right but I
could actually name them this is the
thing WNBA I only know the Britney chick
and I and guys I don't even I have never
I don't even think I've ever watched a
full basketball game that's a crazy
thing I I literally don't think I've
ever watched one outside of like at my
college like watching like the girls and
the guys play but like at an NBA level I
don't
oh wait actually I forgot I went to the
NBA finals I totally forgot I did that I
got free tickets Like A Woman's World
you know what I mean I got free tickets
but not the point not the point I I
don't even watch sports and I can name I
can name five this feminist fighting for
our equality
fighting for our prize money doesn't
even support us in watching
wow
I wish we had her support I wish that
she would just help us break the glass
ceiling and support us but none of these
feminists are ever in the fan in the
stands none of these feminists are ever
spending their Saturday supporting the
team and I know this because there's a
professional team that plays um
that plays in England that's really
really good they're one of the best
basketball teams I have ever seen and
literally there is nobody at their game
it is sad they are probably in the top
like point two five percent of skill for
women's sports
and nobody goes to watch them play now I
could whine and complain and say oh boo
hoo poor me or we could just say it is
what it is and learn to be more
entertaining I cannot stand the
complaining in other news
there is a wife and a mother who was
talking about her aspirations for her
daughter
she was talking about what she wanted
from her daughter so let's pull the clip
oh daughter because after that is a face
eventually she's gonna stop being a hoe
you know what I'm saying I feel like
being a hole is a stage of your life
after a while yeah I want my daughter to
have fun I want my daughter to have that
whole experience
I won my daughter died I don't want my
daughter to be like a church girl she
hasn't experienced life I want I want to
be so cool with my daughter I want my
daughter to be like you know like I
don't know the baby father is you know
or you know I just [__] this [__] and
that [__] I started using protection I
want my daughter to have fun being a hoe
is a a moment kind of thing he's like
you're having fun for the moment it's
like you do it for fun you know you come
back to it you single let me voila I'm
gonna mind me be a little hoe come back
home and I can hold you like I feel like
I want girls to like go out and be hoes
and stop dating one man and just like oh
I love him I love him no go be a hoe go
try different dicks have fun you know
like suck a few different see we surely
like which flavor you like
is it a bad thing to know wives and
mothers lead us to our own destruction
this is a woman saying she's going to
encourage her daughter to be promiscuous
this is a woman who is going to
encourage her daughter to be a hoe she
said she doesn't want her daughter to be
a Church Girl and love a man like how
crazy is this so This Woman
is literally setting her daughter up for
Destruction
and it actually makes me really sad
because it's like women are born with
value so it's like if you give a girl
the wrong messaging from a young age she
can make decisions that will literally
ruin her for the rest of her life like
men can come back you know what I mean
like a guy can [__] up his childhood or
like have a bad teenage years whatever
and they can kind of come back from that
but women it's just not the same it's
like we make
I mean you know she what if her daughter
does only fans what if her daughter does
sex work there's no coming back from
that there's no really being a happy
wife happy mother like
not not really I don't know it's just
kind of sad to me
um
it's actually even more sad that like
men co-sign this
like what what kind of guy
we'll say yes that there's no problem
with that and that's part of the problem
too is men like women are emotions first
men are logic first so men like women
generally think through our emotions and
then if we're like like me it's like I
might have an emotional reaction to
something but then you wait and then you
think logically men it's logic first but
the issue is men have been so programmed
to be women that either there's two
things that happen they either willfully
lie to us or they've been so programmed
by Society to think with their emotions
first you have a lot of feminine men
that tell women what they want to hear
and I just think it's it's sad that
because the result is that the kids
suffer the result in all of this
treachery like the atom 22 stuff this
stuff like it my biggest issue is that
it results in the most innocent people
suffering which is children you know a
lot of times it can ruin women from a
really young age
what I'm really happy about is feminism
fought for women to work now I know
there is property owners in the 1600s
and I know that in the early 1900s or
late late 1800s we had our first female
millionaire I know we had Emperors and
empresses and you know there was women
that were so influential that men
traveled hundreds of thousands of miles
to get wisdom from them but you know we
just couldn't work we were just so
oppressed we just had such a hard
horrible time and we just needed to
fight the patriarchy yes we had to fight
for our rights and thank God we got the
right to to vote and the right to go to
work and just do all of these amazing
things we have a woman that is breaking
barriers and claiming to make seven
thousand dollars a day wow one of our
first female millionaires I'm sure she
added so much value to society I mean
you know when you look at female versus
male male rich people it's like
you know women women add equally as much
value to society we just break down the
barriers we kill the glass ceiling let's
see what this woman is doing to make all
of this money okay gang gang
I feel so good again
yeah amazing
I feel so good now yes popcorn
I'm so glad feminists just fought for
her right to work and just break down
the barriers and just really give it to
the Man 2.5 million a year
what would a man have to do to make 2.5
million a year
what do you think you would ask like
what would a man have to do I don't know
run a business I don't know like what
would a man have to do to make 2.5
million a year
he probably would have to I don't know
invest in real estate I think I saw
Myron talk about how he made
um a Million last year so this girl's
making more than Myron
who runs a full operation has like a
bunch of employees recruiters brings on
the most influential guests in the
country
and she goes on a stream
and then says
bop bop
and yeah and then yeah everyone says I'm
the bad guy when I say women are not
needed to run a society everyone says
I'm the mean person when I say you know
what women
aren't as important as we think everyone
says I'm the bad guy when I say we
really just monetize Beauty when we look
at this at the highest level who offers
more value to society Kim Kardashian or
Elon Musk Bill Gates
I mean she's a arguably a billionaire
and that is the crazy thing women will
always think we're more important than
we are and just say give me credit give
me credit give me credit
so the next story
blue face
and Christian rock
no idea if I said her name right sorry
guys you know me can't do names now now
as you know they have had an on-again
off-again toxic relationship and to be
fair
they're both toxic they're both kind of
crazy like they I've heard them say both
some crazy stuff but
this clip I think portrays the way a lot
of men feel in society after they have a
child with someone
I mean a child is supposed to be a time
of joy and happiness right having
children is supposed to be out of love
and women just do get pregnant and have
a child you know out of love and a lot
of times maybe they're manipulated into
the child and just you know like the
evil men are just getting these women
pregnant you know let's just show the
club so I'm stuck I'm very much stuck
you're not sure I'm not stuck with you
at all no
[Music]
I got zero sympathy well when one of
these rappers entertainers
um men that clearly do not want to be
faithful and clearly are not trying to
be a traditional father yet you you let
them get you pregnant and then whine and
cry later and give me a goddamn sob
story about how hard your life is I just
got no sympathy I got no sympathy and
then what these women want later is for
a nice guy to clean up the mess it's
like okay date oh you're gonna date but
Jesus you do not need to have a child by
them like what happened to you know
there used to be a stereotype of crazy
high school boyfriends like we'd all
heard that the dad gets his like shotgun
to keep the boy away from the girl but
Romeo and Juliet existed for a reason
like it's not like this stuff is new
women liking Bad Boys is not new but
what is new is having a child by them
that is new
why can't you just date the bad boy and
not get pregnant
why and especially I just got no
sympathy in 2023. we have all these
forms of birth control you got birth
control you got Plan B you have abortion
that is legal so if you're a single
mother it is your own choice it is your
own like at that point it's a choice
there's adoption there and now women
will have a kid by a man that does not
want them and then put him on child
support
why why do you deserve his money when he
has made it clear the whole time he does
not want to be with you now a guy quote
tweeted this and said this is how a lot
of men feel when they impregnate the
wrong women but most men aren't as
honest and blunt about it like blueface
guys this is common I did I did a poll
on Twitter this week
I said what percent of women do you
think are quality and I asked men and
women to answer this
okay I had 30 000 people respond to the
tweet
now you could say oh Pearl it's just a
bias you're just you're just buying well
Twitter Twitter everyone's on Twitter
men women like I I would say half the
people that look at my tweets troll me
and hate watch me anyway so let's not
pretend that this is like just a biased
pull when 30 000 people took it 74 of
people said that less than 20 percent of
women are quality and I didn't give them
that was the lowest option I gave them
so I don't even know how it would pan
out if I gave them five percent fifteen
percent and they say that we're harping
on the women that you're just focusing
on the bad women when
thirty thousand people said
that less than 20 percent of women are
quality now
I will grant that yes there are quality
women there are women that want to be
wives want to be mothers and want to
improve there absolutely are but
how
can we have a conversation about these
problems if we get criticized for
talking about 80 percent of women it's
like we'll talk about eighty percent of
women and you're the bad guy for
pointing it out
so even women will agree
that less than 20 of women are quality
now I don't say this to harp on women
but I really just want to wake us up out
of this trance because honestly we have
been lied to and propagated that we
there are quality wives and mothers on
the market I'm sorry there just really
aren't there are few and far between and
if you find one there is a line out the
door for her which honestly kind of
ruins us because we don't do well with a
lot of choice so even if a woman is
quality let's just say she has the wife
and mother skills the problem is there's
20 million men lining up to date her
which kind of ruins our egos too you
know what I mean like then then we get
kind of narcissistic because we're like
oh all these men want to date up date me
then then our ego gets high then we're
ruined you know what I mean so
it's frustrating because the Trad comes
whenever we talk about this problem
we'll just say oh you're just focusing
on the bad women but really the the Trad
cons are equally as feminist as the
non-tradcons and I don't say this to be
mean I don't mean bad people but what I
mean is we have lived a life in
accordance to what feminist wants from
us it's me too this is what Society has
produced so another lie that they have
sold us women is that we have unlimited
time to have children and you can just
freeze your eggs so um there is a woman
that had that was on the cover of
Business Week freeze your eggs freeze
your career
a new fertility procedure gives women
more Choice than ever to have it all
this is a lie that feminism has taught
us that we can in fact Have It All We
yes you can have a career you can have
children now are there women that have
had it all
sure I mean there's probably a couple
women in history that have had a family
and a crazy good career one that comes
to my mind is like that Supreme Court
Justice she had the two kids uh do you
know what I'm talking about there's some
lady she's on the Supreme Court now had
two kids she's married okay there are
exceptions but exceptions do not make
the rule and the rule is that women
cannot have it all now what is the
kicker this woman that has been telling
women for decades yes you can have it
all you can have a family and a career
what's come out the cruel twist of fate
for single women who froze her eggs in
her 30s to free her career she says she
says Bridget Adams caused the sensation
four years ago when she appeared on the
cover of Bloomberg businessweek under
the headline freeze your eggs freeze
your career she was single and blonde a
Vassar graduate who spoke fluent Italian
and working in the tech market for a
number of prestigious companies her
story was one of empowerment how a new
fertility procedure was giving women
more choices as the magazine noted
provocatively in the quest to have it
all Adams remembers feeling a wonderful
sense of Freedom after she froze her
eggs in her late 30s despite the
nineteen thousand dollar cost her plan
was to work a few more years find a
great guy to marry and still have a
house full of her own children but it
didn't turn out the way she hoped
shocker shocker in early 2017 with her
45th birthday looming no and no signs of
Mr Right she decided to start a family
on her own she excitedly unfroze the 11
eggs she had had stored and selected a
sperm donor two eggs failed to survive
the thawing process three more failed to
fertilize the last six embryos of which
five appeared to be abnormal the last
one was implanted in her uterus on the
morning of March 7th she got the
devastating news that it too had failed
Adams was not pregnant and her chance of
carrying her child had just dropped to
near zero she remembers screaming like a
wild animal throwing books her laptops
and collapsing to the ground
so this woman has been selling women the
dream that you can have it all and have
kids in your late 40s and you know what
I noticed too
she worked in Tech and what did they do
in the tech industry it's all like a
system they basically give us this job
these jobs that make us feel like we're
doing more than we are and more
important than we are in all honesty
what do I do I add commentary to society
now I'm not saying this is an important
work and I don't like it but at the end
of the day it is not as important as the
men building the buildings it is not as
important as the men running the
infrastructure of society but women will
get these high paying jobs that are
really subsidized by the men they
basically in these industries they have
quotas and they have money that is
funded by these billionaires out there
what are these evil people that give
them money to increase their their
diversity score and if they hire more
women they get a higher diversity score
so what happens the women get in these
tech jobs they're making way more than
the men so now they're like I don't want
to date the men because they don't make
enough even though it's it's all fake
it's like a fake
so they get these jobs they think they
make more money than they do because the
money they're making doesn't match the
value added to society because the top
men are subsidizing their jobs the men
are doing the real work in these
industries the women are just there to
look pretty let's just call it what it
is and you see this because you see all
the women giving their what I do in a
day at their tech jobs jobs and it looks
like La La Land these women are making
six figures and you see on Tick Tock
there this is what I do in a day and who
got laid off when the rubber hit the
road and all of these tech companies
were unprofitable the women were the
ones that got laid off we saw all these
women crying on Tick Tock about how they
got laid off at their tech jobs because
in all honesty they haven't been held to
the same standards that men have been
held it to and they've just had these
cushy jobs and they have not put in the
same amount of work that men do so
then it eliminates all of their dating
prospects because they may they out earn
everybody it makes them think they're
hotter than they are because they're
around all these high value guys that
don't pick them and then they're told
that they can wait until they're 45 to
have children and most IVF treatments
fail over a certain age I can't remember
off the top of my head what it is but
and on top of that I'm hearing from some
fertility doctors that a natural way
would be more effective
and we keep telling women you could have
it all you could have it all but the
truth of the matter is you can't have
everything and even the women that have
it all on paper I guarantee in some way
the kids suffered because you can't be
in two places at once you're either
raising the kids or you're not
um and I just think it's sad that we
have lied to women and
women we do make our own choices we
absolutely do and at some point we have
to take accountability for the fact that
these are our own choices but it's like
as women we're so silly like we just
believe silly things like why do you
think we still believe in the pay Gap
why do you think we just believe we're
oppressed even though we live life on
easy mode because if you give women a
sad story you say here is a sad story of
a woman being oppressed we just believe
it and we have to start calling this
stuff out because
we'll we'll give a happy story like well
we'll give a happy story of a woman
getting pregnant at 45 and we just
believe it like we hear all of these
stories on social media and we just
believe them we believe the happy
stories of women coming out on top we
believe the sad stories of women being
oppressed and at some point we have to
call out the men that are pandering to
us and the women that are pandering to
us because it doesn't help us
and
you know I you kind of have to make a
choice you can either sit back as a
chick and notice it and once you're red
pill and you see it you can't unsee it
um and you could speak out about it so
other women can know or you can just sit
sit silently so one of the men that
panders to us on a regular basis is
Destiny now I I I've met Destiny he's a
nice guy you know um talks a lot of [__]
he said I was um I saw a clip of him
saying I was just my career was over
yeah it's just been going terrible 50
million views about awful terrible
terrible you know just you know we're
not expanding we're not it's just yeah
horrible horrible anyways so me falling
off nobody will watch this anyway
um let's pull up the destiny clip the
the world's number one panderer destiny
clears podcast host education and
working first they miss that opportunity
to have a child when they're at their
Prime fertility years she can Rectify
that wrong because she got the kids out
to win she can pursue that career after
the fact but if she does the other way
around she might end her immunity to
have children in the future not to knock
any old people but like re-entering the
workforce when you're 40 years old
that's a tall order that's really
difficult but at least it's possible you
can have a kid at 40. that's possible
too yeah it's probably easier to have a
kid at 40 than it is to go into the
workforce after being out of it for 20
years actually yeah absolutely it is of
course you can't have kids I mean let's
be honest dude
it's higher risk
as opposed to a woman at 40 being like
here I am now I'm gonna go get a job I
would argue that a woman has a higher
chance of Landing a job at 40
re-entering the workplace and getting an
education thanks affirmative action
maybe she goes into a job field that's
nominated men versus being 40 years old
and trying to bring a child to full term
sure you would just be completely wrong
do you think it's like a 70 chance of
like a miscarriage woman is pregnant at
40. it's significantly higher
like 90. at that point men like this men
like this simp and Pander to women
he's telling me it's gonna be harder to
get a job
it's harder to get a job at 40 than it
is to have a kid so I just Googled this
fertility specialist quote approximately
a five percent chance of getting
pregnant per menstrual cycle I mean I
wasn't even in social media until three
years ago two years ago
look what I built in two three years you
can't get back your fertility but you
certainly can get skills and provide
value to add to the workforce you know
what's funny I found out a stat the
other day if you hit 30 and you're still
single as a woman
you have less than a 50 chance of having
a kid so you're more likely to not have
a kid than have one because one it takes
time to find a guy that's going to marry
you you know or like want to have a kid
with you and two
um yeah and these are just numbers so
do I think it's harder to get a job as a
woman
and can we stop acting like this is the
other thing like he's acting like women
have all these like high-powered careers
like I think the number one
job for women is caretaking
which you can do with a family
and it's like they just want and then
the the same guys will shame women like
me for calling this out when it's like
you want me to just like watch you guys
lie to women
and say nothing like you want to just
let all the feminists and the leftists
just talk talk talk and and not call
this [__] out
you really you think it's harder like
like let's just let's just use common
sense the average age for menopause is
51.
so at 40 or 10 years away from menopause
and let me get this straight you have a
better it's harder for you to get a job
caretaking
than it is to have a kid and what he
doesn't realize is okay he gets to make
money off of this [__] but it's actually
like detrimental to women that listen to
him it's harder to get to get a job than
have a kid at 40. okay
okay when you have a five percent chance
of conceiving every menstrual cycle
and that's I just cannot stand liars
like and that's the thing Destiny and
you see it because it's so weird
debating him because he just like looks
at his phone the whole debate like the
whole debate he's just like on his phone
like he's not trying to he's trying to
win the debate he's not trying to find
what's true like and it's just like you
can't actually believe that a five
percent all right 40 year old women are
just popping out babies left and right
you see that often I see plenty of 40
year old women with jobs
and I really the funny thing is he
really went into an industry and
dominated in it in the first few years
like he's been on the internet forever
like why is he acting like coming into
an industry
is impossible just because you're old
whatever whatever whatever it's like
he'll he'll pray he'll he'll any
feminist lie he'll like sell the miracle
of like yes you can you can have a kid
at 40. but when it comes to stuff that
he's done and achieved it's like they
they never push like you can do it you
can make money you can go into an
industry and dominate you can change
careers but it's like weird when it when
it serves the feminist imperative it's
like they'll push it like it's likely
improbable but they're the first ones to
say it's unlikely and improbable to like
come in and dominate in the field
okay
but yeah I mean maybe I'm wrong I'm just
a big liar a big you know my career is
just over and ended and I just have the
worst luck just you know I'm just a big
liar and I just hate women I'm a big
woman hater
um but let me know what you guys think
in the comments subscribe to the channel
and ring that notification Bell like the
video on your way out and I'll talk to
you next time